c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la délégation conjointe
entre la cedeao et l'onu s'est rendu ce
lundi à ouagadougou au burkina faso
objectif l'évaluation de la situation
politique dans le pays après le coup
d'état la désertion de la délégation
s'est également entretenu avec le
président renversé roch kaboré la
correspondance dans ce journal l'
escalade entre paris et bamako
l'ambassadeur de france au mali a été
expulsé ce lundi la france prend note et
exprime sa solidarité avec les autres
pays européens présents au mali et
s'engage à poursuivre la lutte
antiterroriste dans la région et à la
fin de cette édition nous irons à
madagascar notre correspondante gaël
borgia nous parlera de la répression
croissante à l'encontre des opposants et
lanceurs d'alert l'un d'entre eux a été
condamné aujourd'hui les détails assure
au burkina faso la junte militaire a
rétabli la constitution du pays elle
était suspendue depuis sa prise de
pouvoir il ya une semaine par ailleurs
les militaires ont modifié les
institutions en attendant la mise en
place d'organes de transition mais
justement une délégation je vous le
disais en titre une délégation
internationale composée de représentants
de la cedeao et des nations unies s'est
rendue ce lundi à ouagadougou objectif
évaluer la situation dans le pays après
le coup d'état des membres de cette
délégation pu s'entretenir avec le
président renversé roch kaboré écouter
nous rencontrons le président officiel
le président roch kaboré
puisque les militaires ont accepté nous
avons eu une courte réunion avec lui il
est de bonne humeur il a l'air bien
il a accès à ces médecins et il est
autorisé à recevoir la visite de sa
famille
et on part tout de suite à ouagadougou
retrouver notre correspondant kalidou sy
kalidou bonsoir la délégation à cedeao
l'onu vient de quitter le pays comment
s'est passée la rencontre avec les
militaires
pas comme vous l'avez montré la
formation trafi pâle et qu'une partie de
la délégation ministérielle la feda aux
conduites par shirley a est encore
bodchon ministre ghanéen des affaires
étrangères a pu rendre visite à
l'ex-président kaboré dans sa résidence
surveillée à signaler également la
présence de mahamat saleh annadif le
représentant spécial des nations unies
en afrique de l'ouest et au sahel car
c'est une mission conjointe cedeao
nations unies selon leurs dires les
discussions avec le mpr mouvement
patriotique pour la sauvegarde la
restauration avec à sa tête le colonel
dan hubbard qu'on était très france le
pouvoir militaire sont des très ouvert
et pour la délégation ministérielle
nationale est plutôt un bon signe à
noter qu'une semaine après avoir été
suspendu la constitution de 1991 est
rétabli c'était une exigence de la
communauté ouest africaine lors de son
sommet de vendredi et cette annonce
tombe justement le jour où une
délégation ministérielle de la cedeao et
à ouagadougou dans un message lu au
journal de la télévision publique
sony dit revenons sur la rencontre du
jour et rappelons surtout que samedi une
délégation de sept chefs d'état major de
la cédéao dirigée par le chef d'état
major du ghana était venu à ouagadougou
pour s'enquérir de la situation
sécuritaire car justement l'argument
sécuritaire et c'est terriblement qui a
été invoqué par la junte comme outil
principal pour renverser le président
habré à coup d'état qui a très largement
quel soutenu par la population de deux
rappels et même si la cedeao a très
logiquement condamné ce coach d'aucuns
se demandent si elle n'aurait pas
intérêt à annoncer un dialogue
pragmatique et constructif avec le mpf
air alors que beaucoup d'organisations
de la société civile reproche à
l'instance ouest africaine de ne pas
être assez aux côtés des peuples et
réclame une cedeao des peuples revenons
à la mission du jour dans l'objectif
était d'évaluer la situation politique
du pays d'entamer des discussions et
d'évoquer un calendrier pour un retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
toutefois aucune annonce n'a été faite
et qu'il s'agissait simplement de
consultation qui décision il ya ce sera
peut-être jeudi 3 février à accra
capitale du ghana pour le sommet
extraordinaire des chefs d'état de la
cedeao et on reviendra bien évidemment
sur cette information est sûre cet
événement avec vous kalidou sy notre
correspondant à ouagadougou la france a
pris note de l'expulsion de son
ambassadeur au mali les tensions entre
paris et bamako semble avoir atteint des
sommets après l' escalade verbale c'est
au tour des réponses diplomatique retour
sur ces tensions avec antoine mariotti
d'assaut la gare et
la situation ne peut pas perdurer c'est
jean yves le drian qui en faisait le
constat il ya quelques jours les maliens
lui ont emboîté le pas et concrétise un
peu plus ce divorce progressif entre
paris et bamako
l'ultimatum a été annoncé sur la
télévision d'état malien de
l'ambassadeur de france à bamako sont
excellents ces jeux est le meilleur a
été convoqué par le ministre des
affaires étrangères et de la coopération
internationale qui lui a été notifié la
décision des gouvernements qu'ils
invitent à quitter le territoire
national dans un délai de 72 heures le
diplomate joël meyer va donc devoir
rentrer à paris dans les trois jours
bamako affirme que cette décision est la
réponse directe aux propos hostiles
tenus par le ministre français des
affaires étrangères il y a quelques
jours jean yves le drian condamné le
retrait forcé du contingent danois sur
ordre des autorités locales et s'en
prenait vertement à la junte au pouvoir
c'est la jungle est illégitime
ce sont les colonels qui ont pris le
pouvoir il confère double coup d'état
depuis août 2000 20 qui est illégitime
et qui refusent la le suffrage universel
qui refuse la vérification démocratique
et qui demande une durée de cinq ans
pour assurer la transition et faire en
sorte que les élections se déroulent
dans la meilleure sécurité une
déclaration qui avait aussitôt provoqué
l'indignation du chef de la diplomatie
malienne interrogé sur france 24 ce sont
des propos empreints de mépris ce sont
des propos que je condamne qui sont
inacceptables et je crois que les
insultes ne sont pas une preuve de
grandeur les relations entre bamako et
paris ne cesse de se dégrader depuis le
coup d'état d'août 2020 avec une
inconnue l'impact potentiel de cette
escalade sur le déploiement militaire
français dans le pays
ou par tout de suite à bamako retrouver
un m'a dit ibrahim kanté enseignant
chercheur à la faculté des sciences
juridiques et politiques de bamako il
est notre invité ce soir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous alors vous êtes sur le
terrain vous connaissez la politique
malienne est ce qu'aujourd'hui on est
arrivé à un point de nombreux tours où
est ce que le dialogue est encore
possible
merci problème ni passion alors on ne
peut pas dire qu est un événement
toujours dans la relation
pas si on parle toujours c'est à 70 qui
monte qui continue à monter jusqu'au
niveau et roncq il trouver des diamants
de discuter pour trouver une solution je
pense actuellement la situation
la relation entre le mali will follow
mallié la france
mais j'ai pas si bien que yo
des reculs et les côtés chapeauté type
est avéré pelli et puis essayer d'aller
sur la base des discussions d'éviter un
père au niveau des métiers parce que
c'est con après les débits mois
seulement cédé au niveau des médias
parce qu'on connaissait déjà la
diplomatie c'est pas le média quitter la
cité mais plutôt au niveau des divers
ministères des affaires étrangères
quitté voix essaye de discuter au niveau
des états pour trouver une solution
concernant la situation room le crise
diplomatique alors là entendu dans le
sujet il ya quelques instants le chef de
la diplomatie française jean yves le
drian avait annoncé au jeudi avait
dénoncé pardon jeudi les mesures
irresponsables d'une junte illégitimes
au pouvoir à bamako est ce que c'est ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres et surtout
comment ce genre de discours est perçue
par les maliens
qui l'écouté je peux parler vraiment au
niveau du malien bex lutte au même
niveau
le
sait les choses au
niveau culturel environnemental au
niveau de nos sociétés alors c'est ça
qui est arrivé avec faire avec le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères avec le mali le maliennes
n'ont pas accepté c'est pas seulement au
niveau au niveau de sommeil dû trouver
plus tôt même si on veut niveau
si on regarde nos niveaux de la
population sur les réseaux sociaux à
tous ceux qui essaient problèmes de
débit s'étaient dénoncés au niveau de la
population locale qui soutient toujours
le pouvoir la transition en cours
actuellement ont troqué ses
députés au niveau de la population lui
au niveau des
commissions alors jean yves le drian est
également pointée du doigt wagner la
société privée russe de mercenaires et
l'accusent de piller le mali sans
chercher je cite à remplacer les forces
anti djihadistes européenne est ce qu'il
dit vrai que peut-on dire de cette
présence de wagner au mali les autorités
n'ont à ma connaissance jamais confirmer
cette présence de ces mercenaires russes
sur le terrain sur le sol malien
effectivement depuis le début de le
gouverner c'est de dénoncer ça depuis le
début le derrière
justement bien
la différence existe un oiseau dit le
mari entretiennent des relations avec
le si c'est pas
de paris vient dénoncer à probabilité
actuellement au mali une manif contre
il en train d'aider le mali au niveau
des sécurités décédé réveiller sur la
question mais ses qualités au niveau du
monde alors je pense toujours au niveau
de la france effectivement
ce qui concerne le riz qu'on
l'a vraiment ce sont des questions qui
est toujours là au niveau médiatique
prévoit si vraiment ça c'est le fait
qu'ils manquent comme quoi le mali a
signé là avec avec manèges et qui ma
mère a été
déployé sur le terrain est conseillé
démontré sa pop est mort jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on a fait ses preuves là et
ça soit au niveau de ma forme et mon
niveau des les états unis alors est ce
que le mali finalement n'est pas en
train de devenir un terrain
d'affrontement entre la russie et
l'union européenne avec la france à sa
tête dans un contexte international que
l'on connaît je fais référence à la
crise ans en ukraine est ce que le mali
n'est pas devenu finalement un moyen de
pression sur la france par la russie
cet immense et
il m'a décrit ce sable et en 2016 le
disait on
la situation qui se passe actuellement
la situation géopolitique avec le
différenciant joie qui c'est qui qui
existe actuellement dans le monde qu'un
plein effet sur le crm seulement le
talent
dans ce
convoi beaucoup de changements
leleu puissance mondiale qui craint des
faits des conférences au niveau des ces
pays là chacun essaie d'aider l'équipe
et de son côté pour qu'ils puissent
effet des points avec la nouvelle
géopolitique qui a changé complètement
de voir actuellement alors bien sûr on
paye et est actuellement le cas du mali
des élus de terrain et confiance entre
la russie et la france alors chaque
petit à sécheresse et à ses amis et des
liens
la russie la bicis avec la chine
titi il accessible qui est d'élire la
france a plus des états unis alors on
veut céder vraiment c'est le mois des
délits le temps entre le 10 ans mondiale
notamment le pays déjà été déjà vers une
crise plus de 80 alors hier solution je
pense bien que le pouvoir
de la rue apple moi qui a fait chuter le
régime des vidéos merci beaucoup ahmad
ibrahim kanté pour votre éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'université de sciences
juridiques et politiques de bamako merci
beaucoup
on part à présent à madagascar un
imposant politique et lanceurs dallaire
de 47 ans mamane nov maher lente a été
condamné à une amende de 1300 euros et
de la prison avec sursis pour avoir
insulté le président est posté une
publication sur facebook jugés
diffamatoires ces dernières années les
arrestations et poursuites contre des
lanceurs d'alerté opposants politiques
se multiplient
on fait le point avec notre
correspondante est anna rivka el borgi
je n'ai pas peur de toi même si tu es le
président de la république tu te crois
supérieur à tout le monde pourtant tu es
un incapable ces publications émaillé
d'insultés à l'encontre du président ont
été postées par un franco malgache de 47
ans manandafy maher lente un personnage
bien connu du grand public puisqu'il est
commentateur télé il se présente
également comme un lanceur dallaire et
il est également le fils d'une figure
politique historique de madagascar
aujourd'hui décédé alors madame est très
suivie sur les réseaux sociaux où il
commente régulièrement l'actualité et il
révèle de temps en temps des
informations qui ne sont pas toujours
vérifié ce qui lui vaut aujourd'hui une
plainte de l'état alors tout est parti
d'une simple publication il ya quelques
jours le président a inauguré en grande
pompe un pont de secours le lendemain
manandafy écrit avoir entendu que le
pont était déjà cassée et donc ce sens
et suivi des publications insultants sur
facebook trois jours plus tard à l'issue
d'un procès express et bien malin daf a
été condamnée à plusieurs n dont une
amende de 1300 euros et de la prison
avec sursis nous avons recueilli sa
réaction à l'issue du verdict je
n'insulterai plus le président de
république mais concernant
les affaires de mon pays
notamment économiques et sociales
je n'arrêterai pas les critiques
la liesse pour avoir échappé à la prison
a été de courte durée manandafy est de
nouveau convoqué à la gendarmerie ce
mardi
dans la seule actualité en bref et en
images la grève de la faim entamée par
free de 40 détenus politiques en algérie
à la démarrer il ya déjà plusieurs jours
une grève pour dénoncer les poursuites
et les fausses accusations dont ils sont
victimes et contre la prolongation
abusive de leur détention provisoire
selon leurs avocats et au maroc le
parquet a requis ce lundi en appel la
peine maximale de 10 ans de prison ferme
contre le journaliste souleymane
raissouni condamné en première instance
à cinq ans de prison l'éditorialiste
d'akhbar al yaoum peu connue pour son
pont critique vis-à-vis des autorités a
été accusé d'agression sexuelle par un
jeune militant lgbt une accusation qu'il
conteste
le parlement libyen a annoncé lundi son
intention de désigner un nouveau premier
ministre à la tête du gouvernement
intérimaire une nomination susceptible
d'exacerber les luttes de pouvoir pour
rappel le gouvernement intérimaire mis
en place il ya un an sous l'égide de
l'onu pour organiser un double scrutin
présidentiel et parlementaire la pauvre
le 24 décembre a échoué
la frontière entre le rwanda et
l'ouganda est de nouveau ouverte après
trois ans de fermeture tout n'est pas
encore réglé entre les deux pays mais
cette ouverture était très attendu elle
permet aux camions d'acheminer les
marchandises surtout vers le rwanda
shirli 6
il pleut et il fait nuit mais après une
minutieuse vérification de leurs papiers
les camions peuvent enfin franchir ce
poste frontière entre l'ouganda et le
rwanda
cela fait presque trois ans que ce point
de passage est fermé alors chauffeur et
habitants sont soulagés
tout va bien nous remercions le seigneur
pour la réouverture de la frontière
c'est vraiment bien qu'elle ait été
rouverte et nous en sommes heureux
on perdait beaucoup d'argent car on ne
pouvait pas passer la frontière parfois
quand on voulait acheter quelque chose
on devait le faire via nos portables
c'est parfois les commandes ne
correspondait pas à nos attentes
maintenant nous sommes heureux que le
problème était raisonnable agnel tous
les problèmes ne sont pas résolus les
différends qui ont amené à la fermeture
de la frontière sont en cours de
discussion le rwanda accuse l'ouganda
notamment de laisser agir des rebelles
hostiles au président paul kagame
l'ouganda lui accuse son voisin
d'espionnage mais cette frontière est
crucial c'est par elle que passent les
marchandises arrivée du port de mombasa
au kenya et qui sont acheminés dans
toute la région jusqu'à la république
démocratique du congo la réouverture de
la frontière est un grand pas en avant
même si tous les voyageurs ne peuvent
pas encore la traversée ont raison des
protocoles qu'ovide en cours de mise en
place selon kigali
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régir
notre chef d'édition célia karacena et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis rester
avec nous l'info continue sur france 24
[Musique]